In this problem, a municipal landfill
uses a compacted 4 foot thick clay liner
that has a hydraulic conductivity of
0.15 ft per year. The records about the
clay paracity have been lost. If the
depth of lee above the clay liner is 8
in and the lee requires approximately 10
years to migrate through the liner, the
estimated pacity of this clay can
reasonably be assumed to be most nearly
65% 55% 45% or 35%.
So this problem is very easy to solve.
All we have to do is take one of our
keywords from our problem statement or
key terms rather. This is going to be
hydraulic conductivity.
So if we go to our environmental PE
reference manual and search for
hydraulic conductivity, we will get to
chapter 3 to a section very clearly
described as the breakthrough time for
lie to penetrate a landfill clay liner.
So we can't get much closer than that.
This equation is going to be given as
follows.
t = d ^2 * new which is the Greek letter
that looks kind of like n over k * the
quantity of d + h where t is going to be
the breakthrough time in years. d is
going to be the thickness of the clay
liner in feet. new or N if I'm going to
get lazy about it is equal to the
parocity.
K equals the hydraulic conductivity in
feet per year and H is the hydraulic
head in feet.
Thankfully this problem gives us all of
the terms that we need to plug into this
equation in order to solve for the
paracity. So t is going to be 10 years.
The clay thickness is going to be from
the 4ft thick clay liner. We don't know
the paracity and the hydraulic
conductivity is given as 0.15 ft per
year.
The hydraulic head is also given. Just
note that this is in inches and make
sure to do the unit equation required to
get it to feet.
Once you're done with that, you can
simply plug it straight into the
equation and get your answer. So 10
years = 4t^ squar * new over
0.15*
the quantity of 4 + 0.83
calculating this out we can see that new
equals 0.45 45 or 45% paracity.
So, there's not much to say about this
problem. If you're lucky enough to see
something like this on the PE, hopefully
it's quick and easy to solve for you.
Otherwise, you might just have to keep
an eye out for more unit conversions or
something like that. And that's it.